hmm you click the video all these videos
on YouTube and you choose mine but why
did they click it what are you trying to
tell me you want me to break down the
ending of you season 4 part 1 and go of
all our theories for what's going to be
happening next time hmm I can do that I
can do that for you be because you
so throughout this video we're gonna be
sorry about that don't know what
happened there you is back and
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the brand new entry and
everything that happens in it if you
want this video I wolf you then please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day a season 3 saw Joe
murdering love faking his own death
dropping his son Henry off at the
neighbors and him traveling out of the
city of love to track down Marianne
unable to find her lovable psychopath
stalker Joe and end up going out to
London after being told that she was an
art fair in our nation's great Capital
Joe managed to track her down but after
realizing that she wanted nothing to do
with him he decided to leave her alone
Marianne called Joe murderer and she was
sickened by the fact to kill love and
countless so there he makes a promise to
prove that he's not that man and since
then he's been going under the name
Jonathan Moore which was given to him by
an assassin named Elliot hired by Love's
father he was sick of the constant death
and he wanted to give Joan out in the
form of a new identity Marianne knew he
was alive though and he was told he had
to kill her so that they could finally
close the chapel drawn Joe or or was it
well now he faked to death and unlike
previous Seasons Joe actually doesn't do
much murdering in this first part
instead the story centers around the Eat
the Rich killer who's picking off his
new circle of friends one by one it's
very much a you done it with us watching
Joe being turned by the killer as he
tries to unmask who they are now in the
end this is revealed to be Reese
Montrose a man of the people who
announces that he's running for mayor
the clues are all there from the off and
in the first five minutes Joe has given
his book titled good man in a cruel
world at the dinner party in episode 1
Joe also looks about and wonders who the
killer could be and the first person who
talks to him is of course Rhys
[Music]
Reese very much sees himself as someone
who's making a change for the GERD and
he's going to do this by stomping out
inequality I was lucky enough to see the
season twice before making this video
and upon meeting him we get a chapter
that Chronicles his childhood born into
poverty and raised by a single mother he
found out he was the son of a Duke and
this sent him into the one percent of
the one percent he promised to clean
things up and he clearly finds common
ground with gel in the club they go to
in episode one he says when he never had
money and you eventually get it feels
like you never really had it at all Joe
says that the rich feel almost like a
different species and this clearly
connects with Rhys who wants to help out
desperate people another species
exactly now the idea of people being
desperate is lacer at the show and early
on Joe saves his colleague Malcolm's
girlfriend Kate from a group of muggers
in his flat Malcolm thanks him while
spouting off a monologue about how
people are trying to bring down the rich
which very much sets up the theme for
this season we see just how Wicked
itself send hidden up their own asses
they are which is exemplified in one of
the main antagonists rolled you actually
don't mind that there's a killer taking
them down and I found myself hoping that
rolled got steamrolled
oh brother this guy stuck thanks now
Reese is desperate for a team with Geo
after he learns who he is and he's
collected an orgy of evidence on all his
past Deeds Joe is very much looked down
upon by the new group of friends and I
don't know why he wasn't just like I
can't be bothered with this I'm off but
bothered he is and he finds himself
going along to all sorts of events when
trying to crack the case now Reese
murders Malcolm and he leave his body in
Joe's flat Joe ends up having to dispose
of this and it inadvertently throws him
closer to Kate she very much becomes the
trademark to you of the season and we'll
talk about the role that she could play
in part two interestingly Marianne isn't
in this part of the Season all that much
but I do think they're gonna bring her
back for the next one however it is
possible that Joe will end up flying
back to Paris so we can have a proper
season there every season so far has
taken place in a new location and I was
surprised that we didn't get this one
there I think things will come full
circle from last time with us heading
out there for the final part or
potentially season 5 down the line if
he's in danger of being caught in
England knowing Marianne is out there
might seal the deal for him and he could
end up returning there to find her again
however there's also the possibility
that the Assassin finds out she's still
alive Love's father would be furious
that he's not actually killing the
people that he pays him for and he might
travel out there to tightly sends saying
that though Elliot does seem like he's
above it now and we do get that face
time scene with him in episode 2 where
he says he's Beyond it and that takes us
in a third time
dude so love stack could find out from
Elliot that Geo's still alive and he may
send his goons to use Mariana's bait Joe
would want to save her because she's the
woman he loves and it would also provide
the perfect opportunity for him to win
her back now initially when she sees him
she does smile but then it probably
Dawns on her how unlikely it is that
he's randomly showed up in London at the
same Market that she's at and probably
all the murders as well I think Joe
thinks he can genuinely win her back
though and is coming together from the
Assassin plot makes a lot of sense in my
opinion Joe going head-to-head with
Love's father to save the person he
loves would be a new way to take the
show and it would give you a reason to
re-enter Marianne's life
check them out
all ramps up to a murder mystery weekend
out in the countryside at Wayne Manor
from Batman 1989 after recognizing them
goggles from the bronkite in episode 4 I
had to look it up and yes that is where
Michael Keaton hung around at in the
film speaking of other movies there's
definite shades of Glass Onion here with
a rich motif of course carrying
over from that too several real murders
happen and one gets pinned on Kate with
yo helping to dispose of the body
however with no one else to really blame
jio becomes the number one suspect and
he's hunted by rolled rolled almost
shoots Amelia and while these events are
actually foreshadowed Elion when he
brings up Dick Cheney didn't your own
vice president shoot someone in the face
obsessed with Kate he's been looking for
a reason to take out the potential love
interest and he attempts to kill Joe at
several points after convincing everyone
that Joe is the killer he chases him out
into the woods but the cunning Fox gets
the upper hand and manages to take him
down at this point Reese steps in knocks
you out and he takes the pair to a
dungeon located probably probably left
of the bat cave now in more Batman
similarities we get a moment akin to the
Riddler wanting to team up with Batman
and it does give us some clues about
what could happen next time hear the
villain monologues and he says that he
has a plan to pin all the murders on
Roll his original plan was to frame jail
for Malcolm's murder and that kind of
made him realize that a dead person
can't protest their innocence thus he
wants child to kill roll to show his
loyalty but Joe ends up refusing resets
the Mansion on fire and says that if Joe
can escape and meet him in London that
he'll reconsider letting him back in
Jonah killing rolled could potentially
show he's changed and maybe maybe he
isn't the bad guy Marianne thinks he is
spoiler alert he still is anyway Joe
saves rolled and the rest of the group
finally accept that he's not the killer
back in the Capital Joe has an awkward
exchange with K where he refuses to go
for a drink with her because he suspects
it'll evolve into something more I think
going forward both recent K will become
the main plot threads in part two that
will both intertwine with one another
throughout the season we learn about
Kate's past and what happened to her
parents which I think sets up things to
come now firstly her mother was a
supermodel called Greta who cracked up
and attempted to end her own life Kate
was then shipped after boarding school
and this happened instead of her father
looking after her we learn his names Tom
Lockwood and then he's also one of the
most powerful men on the planet Lockwood
is known as an activist banker and he
takes companies strips and for pots and
screws over the workers so that they're
left with nothing he seeks the police on
protesters cleanses CEO records of
sexual harassment claims and also gets
well water reports signed that leader
children get in cancer he never hits a
thumbs up button never subscribes and
Kate says that he's the worst man alive
I think this clearly sets him up to be
the target of Reese and I can imagine
that Tom will be brought into part two
okay wants him out as well and I think
it would be really interesting if Joe
actually had to team up with Reese to
take him out to win her love however I
think what's more likely is that it'll
stop Reese whereas the previous seasons
of close out with Joe focusing on a new
girl here we see him staring at recenter
TV screen saying that he'll do anything
to stop you not you not you Rhys you
know I was watching an episode of uh you
where measles came up wait wait when did
I mention measles
I don't know it was on you
what what
was on me what are you talking about my
is this a joke I know what you're
talking about it was on you it was on
you I've never had Raymond I've never
had measles what are you talking about
stupid it was an episode of a show Laura
what's it called
you you it's called you anyway I can see
these threads coming together and then
possibly when Joe's destroyed everything
this side of the country like a Liz
trust budget he can go to Paris on the
search for Marianne I can see that being
the logical conclusion of the entire
thing and with Tom Lockwood getting a
big mention I think this will be the
perfect villain for part two he might
end up with K though and they do keep
calling him Captain America who of
course ended up with a British Peggy
Carter Henry is also still out there too
and Joe did promise at the start of the
Season that he would go back to him I'd
love to see season 5 potentially having
him return to the States but I am
getting a bit ahead of myself there now
as for my thoughts on this season I
didn't really like the beginning of it
and it seemed like you was just going
through the motions again in a new city
however I thought the Eat the Rich
killer was a great change up and I
really enjoyed going through the mystery
of who it was they broke formula for
once and instead of just making Joe the
killer he got someone in for him to face
off against there were some great
inclusions here such as Sean Pertwee and
seeing the rich side crew just ham it up
and be the worst people possible was a
nice way to get us on Reese's side
actually see myself rooting for him more
than anything but obviously Joe doesn't
see himself as being that sort of killer
he won't even cheer pheasant and it
maybe maybe he's changed and I'm not
gonna say the season was a 10. yes I
know I'm a 10. but I do think this is
another ridiculously enjoyable ride even
if it does get off to a bumpy start I am
excited for part two and I'll drop my
full score for the season when that's
out at the moment I'm probably clocking
in about a seven or an eight but yeah I
am excited to see where this stuff with
a recent cake goes obviously I'd love to
hear thoughts on the first part so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in competition right now and
giving away wakanda forever three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be when the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season you beat the comments at
random on the 15th and winners of the
last one are on screen right now similar
to you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of The Last of Us
which will be linked on the screen right
now we're going through it week by week
pointing out all the Easter eggs in it
so definitely get over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace